。
嗯。
好，正式开始上课。同学们，我带你们拉信息节拍拉了这么久。我曾经说过每一个拍都是有信息的，有用的这也是为什么有时候我们会拉出一场戏，会觉得这场戏没有什么用啊，当然啦，很多时候出现在。
不太好的片子里啊，或者是节奏比较松散的电影里面，嗯会有这种情况。但是像这种级别的叙事啊，宏大的叙事。
又是这个嘛顶峰的一个制作。
我们说不太会出现这么一大坨絮去追赶一个没有用的东西。
同学们。
用这么一大坨戏，而且里面还有反还有那个转折，对吧？先自己开车，后来让儿子开车，然后嘞还差点掉下悬崖种种，以为跟丢了啊。但其实他连上了，用了这么多的篇幅去追一个后面根本用不上的道具，你这不扯淡吗？
对不对？用这么长的篇幅去追寻一个后面根本用不上的道具，那是不可能的啊。这个故事信息节拍啊呃，我们说这个故事总长是160分钟啊，如果是按照启程转和四目式的话，那基本上是40分钟啊，40分钟一拍。
拍子反正够大的啊，第一拍我先捋一下基本的拍子啊。第一拍从第一分钟开始啊，一个老太太。
回忆自己的父亲啊。
把这个视角呢切回到过去啊，时间线切回到过去。这个故事里面的时间线啊。
嗯，是有一些多的，但是并不乱啊。同学们所以说并不这么费解，我就不专门去讲时间线了啊。
嗯，老太太回忆自己爹当年啊是个飞行员啊，是个宇航员，然后呢就把镜头切回去。我们的主角呢马叔啊马修麦康纳年轻的马叔啊正在做梦啊，做一个噩梦，做自己坠基的噩梦，就说明他确实是个宇航员啊，也有这方面的噩梦。然后呢，顺便做了他的一个登场。
然后呢，交代了他所处的环境，他是什么什么环境啊？
是一个末日环境啊，末日环境，很多同学很喜欢的一种环境，就是人类要灭亡了。而且这个末日环境主要是来什么啦？主要是来沙尘暴了啊。沙尘暴这个啊，我不知道你们记不记得有几年关于这个沙尘暴会。
会把人类。
呃，严重影响甚至灭掉还是还是挺流行的啊。
然后呢呃也进到了男主的家庭啊，大环境是末日，小环境是这个家庭呃，一直在。
推他跟女儿的关系，然后呢，也适时的推出了这个。
这个这个关于幽灵的这个探讨啊，父母才是孩子的幽灵啊，这个世界上没有幽灵，父母才是孩子的幽灵。这个推出了幽灵的探讨。我们看到后面知道这是伏笔啊啊，这是第一第一部分的内容。第二部分的内容，开车出去啊，爆胎了，爆胎呢顺便讨论了一下关于morph菲啊，关于morph菲定律。
呃，孩子叫morphphy嘛。呃这时候呢进入刚才我们看的这个小比喻啊，小比喻发现了无人机啊，然后呢去追这个无人机，操控无人机降落，这个获取这个无人机的电池。然后呢，在这期间一直在铺垫父女关系。同学们这对父女的关系。
非常好啊非常好。嗯，这个我们后面可以探讨。第三部分啊，来到学校见老师，儿子呢上不了大学，说女儿呢惹了麻烦啊，呃而且惹的这个麻烦呢是比较正义的麻烦啊。因为学校里面改教材啊，不承认有人登陆过月球。这个在当年也是社会热点啊。
当年也有也有一部分人说这个这个登陆月球那个阿姆斯特朗这件事情呢是是是实是假的啊，假的。来到第四点，我们说第三点在学校其实还是在做儿子和女儿的人设，和这个父亲护独子啊，以及再次探讨naSA的事情啊，有naSA已经不被信任了。
你可以理解，在这里暗示nasA已经不被信任了啊，naA被迫都关掉了，不被社会信任。然后第四part啊第四part来到第14分钟，因为联合收割机出问题啊，然后很多机器都被吸引到同一个地方，然后呢包括书架上掉落的书啊，似乎在表达些什么，这里就不断的营造悬念啊，不断的营造悬念。
然后呢也结合了一些回忆的视角哈，来到第五拍啊呃这个18分钟正在看球赛的时候，沙尘又来了啊，把这个沙尘展现给观众看一下。因为之前一直说沙尘这个这个要毁灭世界了，还没这个直观展示。
然后呢，大家比较熟练的紧急撤离，因为见怪不怪了嘛，回到家啊再次出现异象。
沙尘散落在地上，而且是一个二进制的坐标啊。然后第六拍男主开车去坐标处解密，然后女儿也偷偷跟来了啊。然后呢，他们黑夜抵达了那里，发现这个地方很危险啊。第六拍啊，第七拍来到第25分钟，原来这里啊是拉萨啊，是航天局是拉萨。
呃，这些人呢依然在坚持啊寻找新的方法找离开呃保护人类，离开地球啊。最重要的这一拍内容是什么？向主角发出召唤啊，你曾经是最好的宇航员。当然这里还有一个细节啊，在第七拍里这里还有一个细节，同学们讲的是nasA为什么被取缔了，是因为当年他们拒绝向平民投放炸弹，这里是一个小小的暗示啊。
意思就是在发生灾难的时候，有权有势的人会决定消灭一部分人类来保持口粮的充足啊，但是呢这个nasA给拒绝了，你也可以理解这个无人机为什么在天上飞了十年啊因为执行任务的那些部门可能都都灭掉了啊，这些直升机本来就是要无人机本来就是要。
又干掉人类了啊啊，但是对于我们的故事来说啊，这里讲的是主角受到了召唤啊，这个召唤非常明显啊，第八拍来到第32分钟啊，然后呢召唤了，那肯定不能一下就召唤成嘛，然后开会啊解释呃这个naA这些新计划的原理。
是因为有个虫洞啊，通过这个虫洞一下就可以干到另外一个星系，而且已经去了12个先驱者了啊，这12个先驱者活上自己的命，先去探路了。他们现在呢往回发信号，对吧？谁找到适合居住的就往回发信号。
是这么个原理啊，同学们理解这个逻辑啊，这是他们为什么上路的原因。就是我们已经派了12个人出去。他们如果能找到适合人类生存的地方，会往回发信号。现在你们可以去接收信号去了，而且呢还有AB计划啊，同学们记住这里AB计划很重要啊。A计划呢，就是你们找到地方，然后回来接我们，把人类接过去。
穿过虫洞到另外一个星系去找前12个先驱者留下的线索，这样可以增大我们的获胜的概率。但是呢我们依然有AB计划，A就是你们找到这个星挺好挺得是吧？有空气有水，那你们就回来接我们，我们这个大飞船呢，能能跟诺亚方舟似的，能把人接过去，是吧？
呃，普lan B是什么呢？B计划是什么呢？是这个你们去的这个飞船上呀，我们也给你们带上了相当数量的优质受精卵啊，你们去那儿就孵蛋就可以了，对吧？万一回不来，对吧？你们就在那孵蛋啊。好，基本上就这么个意思啊，来第九。
第九拍男主角显然是接受了任务啊，显然是接受了任务。所以他回到家之后呢，女儿就生气了啊不让他去啊呃女儿帮他拒绝召唤。在这个故事里面啊，我们说召唤与拒绝召，因为召唤完了之后要拒绝一轮嘛，他这个拒绝是放在女儿身上的啊。
然后嘞。
这个再次强调呃，父母是孩子的幽灵啊，这个暗示再暗示一遍，看到后面的同学当然知道是怎么回事啊，然后这里那个咒语stay啊，留下。
那个那个那个留下来啊，留下来这个say啊再一次。
成为了一个咒语。
成为这个一个咒语，我们就知道啊，在这种情况下为什么要做咒语？同学们。
为什么我们在主角上路之前经常要搞些咒语啊？就是为了啊。
通过孩子的嘴说一个咒语。
让观众觉得完了忒危险了。
啊，让观众觉得太危险了啊，来到第十拍啊，第十拍告别。
你跟女儿生气状态的一个要抱告别，然后就上路了。当然了，你也可以把这一拍跟下面出发捏在一块儿。但是呢我我觉得既然一个离开一个征上征程，咱们就把它分开啊，这里就是第十拍和女儿的告别。女儿现在是生气的，不理他啊，离开啊，下一幕第1一拍呃42分钟这里啊。
呃，这个这个火箭升空倒计时啊，仪式感都嘎的啊。我们说这这一拍啊，实际上以诺兰的这个我们说第二第二个往天上升天啊，其实给的细分不多。我们来看一下这场戏啊。
作为这么一个关键节点，给的私分不多。
给你看看啊，先是告别道路的这个仪式感啊给的不多。基本上这个男主离家的时候，开着车离家的时候吧，就他妈火箭那个点火就已经开始倒计时了。然后过来之后就开始伺火啊。
我们也看着看可以看出来，你像这大导演，有时候也挺任性的啊，这么贵的一个镜头，这么漂亮的一个火箭升空，这么真实，他不用啊，就用个一两秒，对吧？就用个一两秒，咱们呢也无法揣测他是怎么想的。反正在这里相当任性啊，其实因为这个镜头其实是很漂亮的，也很贵的。来到第12拍也就第44分钟啊，我们说。
呃，上路之后先是伙伴，同学们。
在这里伙伴就是三个人加一个机器人啊，上来上来就是伙伴啊。当然了，他结合伙伴也推出了第一个目标啊，推出了第一个目标。
我们说像这种叙事啊，这很明显的是一个任务导向型的一个故事，对吧？几个人要去执行一个任务啊，所以说他的这个大目标会拆解成。
无数个小目标啊无数个有点夸张了，会拆解成很多的小目标。然后这一个一个小目标的实行，就是这种片子的节奏。对，这很典型，是一个金羊毛啊。
太空金羊毛，所以说上路之后。
紧接的非常紧，交代各种同伴的时候就开始。
扔出第一个目标了，然后来到第十三拍，第46啊呃这个第一个目标顺利完成，也就是对接那个母舰。然后呢呃进去之后呢，和地面取得了联系，进展一切的很顺利啊。
来第十四拍，我们说进入第二幕，伙伴和目标收拾差不多了，就开始要起情感线了啊。在这里啊第50分钟啊开始啊深度交流，然后呢录录视频给孩子们啊，录视频给孩子。
我们说情感啊明显的小味儿一下就提上来了啊。
来第15拍，第54分钟，这个你可以跟十四拍连在一起，但是也可以拆开。就在地球端啊，这个视频收到了之后啊，女儿还在生气。然后呢，他在飞船里呢等到女儿的视频啊，我们说这是十5拍十六拍呢啊下一个目标重动。当然了，在这里由于啊伙伴，我们说伙伴的戏份相对较少。
在之前没有什么伙伴的戏份。所以说在这里，其实每一次制定新目标的时候，都会把伙伴之间的差异以及大家之间的关系，谁服从谁谁激励谁，多去交代一下啊，在这里肯定要刻意的把伙伴往下拉一拉。同学们知道为什么啊，因为这个伙伴后面都牺牲了。话那你在这里就得赶紧给戏份。
啊，赶紧给媳份。
哪怕给一个比较扁的人设，对吧？让大家知道他们是勇敢的人，正直的人好吧？或者是有血有肉的人，好吧，因为他后面要死嘛，所以说这里肯定要抓紧时间把这个伙伴搞一搞啊搞一搞。然后第16块呢，这个目标是虫洞呃，营造了一些这个呃呃飞船还是有点危险的啊，这虫洞里面也不是闹着玩的。
但是呢穿过去了穿过去的来到了另外一个星系啊，来到了另外一个星系。对，这里有个小小的握手啊，小小的握手，一个小浮笔小点缀。
第十七拍第62分钟啊，62分钟接到信息啊开始选择探测顺序。接到那那12个先驱者的信息了嘛，是吧？开始选这个呃探测顺序啊，我们的这个男主制定计划，然后呢，那第十八拍就是呃来到第一个星球是吧？66分钟来到第一个星球。
呃，展现了那主角的这个艺高人胆大啊，很惊险的降落在这个水面上啊。
然后第1九拍68分钟，这个星球呢一个小时7年，所以我们的主角很着急啊。在这里啊其实展现了我们主角是非常的思念他的女儿的同学们。
我们回忆一下啊，在这里其他人都是以拯救地球为主要目标。但我们的主角是以回家。
抱女儿为主要目标啊，他很着急，你们一默迹回去，我女儿都比我都大了。
然后呢，但是只找到了残骸啊，面对这个巨浪。
我们的这个女主呀比较执着于去抢救数据啊，结果导致伙伴牺牲了啊，导致伙伴牺牲了。第20part72分钟啊，等牺牲了一个伙伴还不算飞船进水啊，起飞不了，结果浪费了这个几十年的时间。然后我们这个男主啊男女主就理念不和啊，这里就展现出来男女主的理念不合。
啊，男女主的理念不合。
21拍来到77分钟啊，我们的男主强行起飞啊强行起飞。
回到了空间站，然后过去了23年，然后第二二拍出现了这个戏。
第一个封神的场面。
当年我在电影院看这场戏的时候，就就真的就是感觉应该跪着看。第22拍第79分钟，他们23年过去了，他们回到了飞船上失去了23年，然后展现23年来收到的信息视频。
女儿已经和她同岁了。
这咨询什么。
这是是去。
嗯。
配的る。
你死了佩去。
Never made one of these when you were still responding because I was so mad at you for leaving.
嗯那个因为快。
开始录过他这是的呀。
Today is my birthday.
A special one because you told me.
You once told me that when you came back, we might be the same age.
Today on the age you where when you left.
这就是。
这个电影的一个名场面啊，当年是非常的这个震撼啊非常的震撼。
当然了，配合演员无比扎实的演技啊。马修麦康纳我说过啊，他是演员当中的六边形战士，来到第二次三拍，也就是83分钟啊，83分钟。这里有一场很重要的戏在地球上啊啊也就是这场戏接着的啊，因为镜头切到地球上了嘛。在这场戏里面非常重要的事。
偷偷开始展现一件事情，墨菲长大了以后在干什么？墨菲长大了以后，跟那个博士一起在研究playA了啊，这很重要啊。而且墨菲还能提出一些自己的方法解决问题啊。
开始双向奔赴。当然了，这里也打一个伏笔，为后面没有普莱A让我们的morphphy非常伤心。但是更重要的是，morphphy最后也是拯救世界的一分子啊。
在这里开始搞了。
第二十四拍。
来到85分钟，又一个新目标，这个呃呃又又又产生新计划新目标啊。但是这次呢男女主有争执，二选一两条路二选一。这个这个这个男女主各自有各自的立场，因为燃料不够啊，燃料不够，只能选最大的可能性。所以二选一。这场戏其实非常残酷啊非常残酷。
两个人都在发出信号，说明两个人都活着，对吧？大家去二选一，这种事情其实是很残酷的。明白这种这种戏啊，其实是完全可以做出做出残酷的感受的。而且确实也做了啊，做了这个女主跟其中一个人是有这个是有这个爱情啊，有爱情。然后第25拍来到。
第89分钟啊再次展现一下。
地球上的地域景象啊，镜头再切回一张地球上。因为从故事的终点往后啊，我们说这个故事一共是160分钟，基本上是40分钟左右一拍啊，40分钟左右一幕。
终点以后，女儿长大以后，基本上就承担了女主的作用了啊。女主其实不是安妮海瑟薇，女安妮海瑟薇就是个伙伴啊，就是个伙伴，充其量就是个伙伴。
这部戏严格的女主肯定是morphphy。morphphy同学们啊，我们不管评奖参奖怎么送，说谁是主角，谁是配角。但是在这部电影当中啊，这个这个安妮海瑟薇伙伴的意味更大啊，伙伴的意味更大。然后那个女主。
呃，妥妥的应该给到morph菲啊，因为morph菲是跟主角双向奔赴来拯救这个世界的啊回来我们说到这儿。
呃，25拍是展现地球上这个这个地狱一般的景象啊，这个这个主角的儿子和女儿吃饭暗示这个之前一个孩子也是肺不好走掉了。现在这个孩子肺又不好啊。然后更重要的是什么呢？老教授也挂了啊，老教授挂了之后，这个这个接力棒交给morphphy的时候，morphphy才知道。
一直的就只有B计划啊，A计划没打算实施。
来到第26拍，95分钟啊，这个飞船探索这个。
这个地球啊，我们说啊刚才那个争执二选一啊，最后听的是男主的。
然后展现这个新的呃探索这个新的精球，这个新的星球跟上一个星球地貌不一样啊，上一个全是水，这个全是冰是吧？极寒之地，然后找到营地，唤醒了休眠中的马特达蒙是吧？马特达蒙这次没有种土豆。
这次呢在这睡大觉，哎呀。
然后呢，马特达蒙说自己。
这个这个已经等的绝望了啊，这个但是这个星球呢是有一定希望力。
27拍来到101分钟啊呃morph非的消息发过来了啊，教授死了，而且拷灵魂拷问我们的呃他的父亲。
呃，从头到尾只有B计划这件事情啊呃被捅破了啊，在我们的主角团队也捅破了。从头到尾就只有B计划28拍103分钟啊，呃产生了争执啊。当然28拍你也可以归在27拍里面。因为得知只有B计划呢产生了争执，但单独列出来是为什么呢？是因为我们男主已经明确表示自己要回家了，我不干了，我要回家。
呃，关于物种的延续是否高于当前的亲情，产生了巨大的争执。这个我们说这些争执啊，大家都是蛮有质量的啊。关于物种的延续是不是高于当前的亲情，对吧？整个人类的命运和我的女儿到底谁重要，对吗？对这种事情确实是可以争得起来，吵得起来。
呃，男主明确表示他要回家。
第29拍来到105分钟啊。
morph尔菲开始想起伴随他长大的这个幽灵啊，也就是他父亲的这个呃这些指示啊，这这里还没有揭露是他父亲的指示啊，想起把这些幽灵开始要找新的方法了。
然后第3十拍啊第3十拍。
我们的男主啊执行最后一个任务啊，在星球上建个制建个基地啊，记住他就这个事儿完事儿他就要回家了。第30分。
第31拍呢来到112分钟，就马特达蒙啊突然反水了。第112分钟啊，我们这个马特达蒙突然跳反。
他要杀死这个我们的这个男主，因为这个星球啊根本就不适合居组，他那些数据全是假的对吧？然后呢，第32拍。
来到113分钟啊，我们说在地球上啊，兄妹家庭也要破了，然后孩子也生病了，然后呢进入一个这个这个这个治暗的时刻啊，灵魂的黑夜。
然后与此同时，平行剪辑115分钟第33拍，我们的男主角也被打破了面具，出现了一个濒死的状态啊，也到了灵魂黑夜。也就是说两边呼应着啊，地球和另外一个星系，两边呼应着都进入了至暗时刻啊，都进入了至暗时刻。
来到第34拍啊，第34拍118分钟，男主呢向女主求助，然后女主来救他，把我们的男主救了。呃，不是女主啊，呃我习惯性的叫喊女主，其实就是那个伙伴啊安妮海瑟薇啊。
然后第35拍来到120分钟啊。
这个morphphy呢也想到办法，然后这个也救了家里移，为了孩子的健康，逼迫家里人转移，点燃了这个玉米地是吧？
呃，36拍122分钟啊啊，我们的男主获获救以后呢，去追逐这个马特达蒙，追逐这个叛徒的飞船啊。然后这个叛徒呢尝试和母舰对接失败，强行出仓。但是呢爆炸了爆炸了，这里搞就搞出事了啊，损坏了母舰啊，损坏了母舰。
然后第37拍啊来到129分钟，我们那个主角。
尝试拯救这个母舰啊，拯救这个母舰呃去呃。
这个方法我就不说了啊，跟着这个母剑一块转啊，一块儿转。在这个非常高的离心力的情况下，几乎晕厥的情况下，对接成功面完成了局面。也就是说从灵魂黑夜延续到现在的危机，嗯，这个被我们的主角给拯救下来了啊，被我们的主角给拯救下来了。
来到第38盘啊，132分钟。
呃，新的问题是什么呢？这个母舰已经损坏了，回不了地球啊，回不了地球。但是刚才不是记得刚才男主和那个安妮海瑟薇有一个争执说去哪个星球嘛？对吧？男主认为现在的燃料勉强可以到达安妮海瑟薇男朋友所在的那个星球，因为那个星球。
也反馈了一些相对好的信息。所以他的计划是我们去那边，好吧，这是我们男主的新计划。
第39拍啊，第134分钟执行新计划，执行新计划啊，但依然是一个极限操作。而且在这个计划里面。
我们的男主或许将永久错过和女儿的见面。也就是说我们的男主已经把女儿的利益高于一切，基本上放下了，因为他也回不了地球了，对吧？所以说他铤而走险，第40拍第37分钟啊嗯伙伴们接连牺牲，呃呃不是伙伴们接连牺牲。最后一个伙伴是这个机器人啊，机器人也算一个伙伴啊。
肯定是被抛弃了啊，因为它挺沉的，有重量啊被抛弃了。抛弃了之后，我们的主角竟然也做出了自我牺牲啊，把节省出来的燃料送给安妮海瑟薇去拯救地球。也就是说我们的男主做出巨大的自我牺牲啊，愿意牺牲自己的生命来保全这个地球。
来到第41，结果我们的男主呢进到黑洞了，被弹射到了一个。
这个这个这个不明的空间啊，第42排来到第141分钟啊，这个不明的空间原来就是个五维空间啊。在五维空间里啊，我们这个时间是以是以直观的方式展现。然后呢这个能够穿透空间的是重力。
所以说呢这个。
嗯，他可以在这个五维空间里呢看到不同时期的女儿啊，可以也可以给不同时期的女儿发信息啊，产生交流啊，自己呢真真正正的成为了女儿身后的鬼魂，对吧？呼应了开场和呼应了开场。而且在这个五维空间里，他还跟机器人联系了，机器人也被弹到这儿来了。
那个机器人也被弹到这里来了啊，这个是一个小惊喜。呃，当然了呃弹过来也是有作用的。因为机器人相当于是一个人工智能嘛。
可以帮他这个可以告诉他各种解决方法，然后他再把这些解解决方法呢告诉女儿啊告诉女儿。
第43拍150分钟啊150分钟呃，morphphy那就成为了拯救这个世界的希望。因为他们采集的数据全部在机器人这里，机器人呢跟我们的男主在一起，我们男主呢能跟地球上沟通的唯一的人就是他女儿啊，所以他将扮演一个信使，然后呢用那个他送给女儿的这个手表的方式啊。
送给他女儿这个手表的方式，然后嘞。
去去去让让女儿知道啊，让女儿知道这个信息。
然后呢，把这些数据和方法这个。
告诉女儿，那女儿找到了答案，自然拯救了自己，改变了历史啊，改变了进程。他女儿找到了答案，那就改变了历史后续发展的进程。然后这个五位空间呢也就也就直接就就崩塌了啊，这个五位空间也就直接崩塌了。至于能不能改变过去，我们在这个片子里面依然不去讨论啊，依然依然只理解平行空间。
否则科幻片就没得拍了啊。
呃，故事到这里啊，四募就结束了啊，其实四幕就结束了。然后后面呢又给了大家一个安放情绪的呃结局。我们自己来看一看最后这四拍安放情绪的结局。当然你可以思考要不要这个结局。嗯，我为什么一直强调结局是赠送的？在这部电影里面也是表现的挺淋漓尽致的啊。
第44拍啊，赠送的结举有4拍啊，第44拍第1515分钟啊。
呃，男主获救啊，在空间站醒过来，在空间站其实也就是一个呃A计划啊，A计划成功了呃，这个重新建了一个人类的家园，而且在这里得知女儿还活着啊，女儿还活着。
45拍啊呃157分钟竟然找到自己的老伙计机器人，，并且把老老伙计呃这个这个这个呃呃这个重生复活了啊。
第46拍来到160分钟呃，来呃这个见到了morphphy啊，这个父女情把他收收官啊，46分钟啊，父女情收个尾。
47分钟，他选择了继续上路啊，去寻找他最后的那个战友。
47分钟啊47拍来到162分钟啊。
这个他选择了继续上路，寻找自己最后的战友。
说是一个非常。
非常美食，非常理想。
理想主义英雄主义的一个结尾。
你说一个老头儿120岁，经历过虫洞和黑洞的还有五维空间的折磨，好不容易醒过来，在床上还昏迷了好几年。
刚醒，你们就让他去一个人去执行太空任务。你们这年轻人在这里安逸的生活了几十年，就没出来一个宇航员吗？
而且新的飞船我跟你说，那有可能操作系统都。
都升级好几回了，是不是你这老头出来都以前是按钮，现在都触屏了。
是不是啊？
这多少是有点过分了。
是不是多少有点过分了。
开玩笑啊，随意啊随意。
作者这么写，肯定有他的道理啊，也也有他一些很浪漫主义的情怀在里面啊，很浪漫主义。好吧，其实最后这四拍啊都是赠送的。我一直说啊赠送的结局。
就不要去赠送的结局，这种东西啊，咱们就不要去不用特别在意，呃，确实可以探讨，可以更换啊，确实可以探讨，可以更换。同学们。
我们来总结一下啊我们总结一下。
首先说一下这个故事啊，这个故事。
我记得是13年14年左右啊，确实是。
当年出来的时候相当的惊艳啊，14年是吧，相当的惊艳啊，惊艳了整个世界。
让世界看到原来科幻片还可以这。
特别是里面这个关于。
这个时间折叠了以后。
女女儿比父亲大，然后甚至还有连续看23年都发生了什么这一段神奇的表演表演。我们说。
这种戏啊给到演员，那真的是爽到了啊，演员简直就爱爱死了这种戏可以疯狂的发挥呀，疯狂的发挥。我们说这场戏里面。
西欧麦康纳。
这个一分钟里面要。
看那么多的视频，要表演那么多的状态，对吧？这个。
太厉害了啊，这太厉害。
然后呢。
嗯，引发了我同学们一些一些问题啊，就关于科幻片还可以这么拍。很多同学说老师这种题材类型是不是就叫科幻片啊，我们不能去理解啊不能去理解。
所谓的。
这种说故事类型是科幻片，一定要搞清楚故事类型和题材类型的区别。我们说这个题材你当然可以说它是个科幻题材。
当然可以说他是个科幻题材，，但是它不是个故事类型啊。
很多同学总问，老师科幻片怎么写？我们是讲故事原理的，我们只管故事咋写。这个故事在我们园里，它就是个纪要文。
对吧几个小伙伴为了执行一个任务，对吧？一个天选之人，为了执行任务，对吧？人家说就是你啦，必须你去。然后呢，他接受了这个任务，抛弃了家人，抛弃了情感，执行这个任务。然后呢，在路上结识了伙伴，把收获了友情。然后在这个过程中又做出了牺牲，做出了自我牺牲，最后呢实现了目标，但是人也回归了平凡。
我们说这这在我们看它就是一个呃金羊毛嘛，只不过是个太空金羊毛嘛，对吧？这个至于科幻啊，它只是一种元素，或者是一种题材啊，是一种题材的。所以说在这种情况下，我们是呃不认为它是故事类一型啊，它只是题材类一型。而且关于科幻啊来强调一下。
科幻一共有8种类型，同学们自己先记啊，回头自己去记笔记。科幻片一共分8种类型，时间穿梭。
机器人去。
外星来客。
外星探险外星来客和外星探险不一样啊，一个是往里走，一直往外走，然后赛博朋克世界末日。
基因突变，太空歌剧，这是所有科幻类型的科幻题材啊，他们常写的一些方向。那你说这个故事里面啊，这个故事我们说那肯定是外星探险去寻找新的地方，但是它也套了世界包日。
所以说这个东西啊，同学们千万不要说哎呀，我被类型被体在人术缚。没关系的。来，我们今天再强调一下啊，信息包指的为什么叫信息包信息这块呢？那就是产生新的信息了呀。当然了，你说每场戏它怎么都有新的信息。我们这里指的新的信息是在剧情角度能产生新的期待或者新的指向性的东西，我们把它理解为新的信息包，好不好？从从这个角度我们去理解。
好吧，所以呢在这种情况下产生新的期待啊产生新的期待。我们就我们就把它理解为一个信息胞啊，当然了，你们在拉信细胞的时候，跟我有出入，也不用去也不用去担心啊，这8个分类不是我给你们分的。
是专门研究电影史的人分的，我不太喜欢分类，就像这部电影，诺兰肯定也不喜欢分类，他就用到好几种，对不对？诺兰这部电影他就用到很好几种呀。对，没有什么标准的界限，我不喜欢分类，这是以前中国电影中国电影杂志是以前呃同常不要小看当年的纸媒啊。
在在网络兴起以前，纸媒是非常厉害的啊，他们不光有话语权，他们甚至有资源。也就是说在中国最早引进什么电影，翻译什么电影，都是这个这个媒体是相当强势的。所以说当年这个纸媒非常厉害。中国电影杂志的主编，那是相当相当厉害啊，相当这个这个是中国阅片量排第一的人啊。
所以说是他们给出的一个。
完吗？
所以说那这个故事啊从我们的类型角度来讲，就相当相当会是这个明显啊，特别非常王化。
然后这个故事的主题啊。
当然了呃。
变认为的主题啊，什么爱能拯救世界不变认为的主题是爱能拯救地球是吧？拯救人类是吧？爱能击穿一界，爱能这个这个跨越时空，爱能爱能拯救。
有这个人类啊嗯但是在我们课程上啊，我们普遍理解主题是个topic，是个话题吧，主题主题嘛是个话题，啊其实是在探讨父女情况对吧？双向奔夫呀，对吧？相互信任呀，相互理解呀，互富无全女呀，这些你都有。
看到下一个东西，关于金羊毛当中的感情线，我们说在这个故事里面，金羊毛的感情线，金羊毛故事里面的感情线放在第二幕上路之后啊，上路之后，我们说在上路之后，我们用视频通话。这个当年是第一个用啊，诺兰是当年是宇航员可以跟家人进行视频加书。
这个其实算是月诺兰的一个发明啊。
用这个方式确实是极大的调动了父女之间的感情，对吧？当然到后面还可以用那个书架，那就更厉害了啊。呃，所以说这部戏当中，我们说他的情感线啊伴随着呃这个这个这个第二幕。当然第一幕里面人家父女在一块的时候也挺挺挺挺挺腻歪，挺好的。
但是后面直升级直接用的就是这个啊视频视频信视频信件这个东西啊，在第二部确实是开始就是有一个非常重要的力量。呃，所以说这部电影从故事类型上说是非常单纯，非常干净的啊，是标标准准的金羊毛啊，包括啊去寻找目标，抽空目标，调整目标，然后伙伴的伴随伙伴的牺牲，然后最后呢绕个动作实现愿望，对吧？。
这个故事啊就是一个相当的一个呃相当标准的啊标准的再来看一下这个故事的角色，好不好？我们说这个故事当中有四种价值观，同学们记一下，为了个人的利益而选择忠诚的。
是男主，为了集体的利益而选择忠诚的是伙伴，也可以理解为男儿，对吧？安妮海瑟薇其实是个男二啊，你可以说他是女二都无所谓。为了集体的利益而撒谎的人，小反派也就是那个教授老教授啊，小反派。
他死了吗？死了我们就原谅他了，对吧？因为他是个小反派啊死了吗？为了个人的利益而撒谎的是大反派。
我刚才说的这四句话，同学们观察一下其中的规律啊，好人阵营都是忠诚的对手或者制造阻力的都是撒谎的。但是区别是什么呢？我们的主角忠诚于什么啊？忠诚于家庭，对吧？那我们的伙伴呢，我们其他执行任务的人呢，忠诚于集体。
对吧忠诚于集体，忠诚于崇胞的目标。然后呢，制造对手的制造主力的那些对手，或者我们称之为大大大反派小反派都是撒谎的。小反派呢他撒谎说AB计划，实际根本没有A计划对吧？就撒谎，大反派呢就为了个个人利益而撒谎，他自己想活命。
对吧他自己想活命，想让别人来救他，然后撒谎。马特达姆。所以我们可以理解啊，从古往今来的故事来说啊，我曾经跟大家讲过，如果你的主角对吧？你的主角的底线是忠诚。
如果一个主角没有优点，你就让他坚持坚持也是一种忠诚。主角的底线是忠诚。所以说在这部电影里面啊，面对这个一个比较大的事儿啊，我们说在设定角色方面出现了四种价值观是挺有意思。由于他出现的比较全，出的比较全啊，我们呢就可以看的比较明确啊，看的比较明确。
这也是为什么我们从来不觉得灭霸特别坏。就关于这种大科幻题材啊，大科幻题材，我们以后怎么处理？金羊毛是会写。金羊毛是简单的啊，普通金羊毛我们是能写的，但是这个电影呢由于它是个大科幻啊，宏大趋势，我们尝试啊从里面学几点。首先从金羊毛角度依然是一个伙伴的设定任务的拆解，对吧？以及主线目标的宏大伟大吸引人。
我们说从金羊毛的角度是简单的，主线目标够大，我们的主角又是天选之，伙伴设定各个有趣。然后呢目标拆解有层次，拆成四五个。金羊毛是没毛病的，同学们理解吗？就这个故事从金羊毛的角度实际没什么说道。
一点都不比那个就这个故事，单从金阳猫角度看，我觉得都跟就都不比绿叶仙踪复杂。但是我们我们同学要搞清楚啊，宏大叙事也要包裹一个。
小主题。
很多同学说老师，我觉得这个故事包的这个呃呃父女情的主题呃太太太矫情了。呃，我刚才解释过了啊，这是文化背景的差异。而且也不是说我所有的东方观众都觉得他矫情，实际上还是有相当一部分人是喜欢的啊。
呃，我们说这个宏大趋势啊，你也不要害怕啊，包一个小点的主题，这个方法是没有毛病的啊。我们说这是关于打科幻，我给大家给大家的第一点忠告啊，第一点忠告。第二点忠告呢，就是关于这些科幻的点，同学们有没有看到在这部电影里面。
在解释这个这个黑呃这个虫洞里面时空的折叠，为什么可以迅速的到达另外一个系，就像一张纸折在一起，对吧？然后呢，解释什么叫五维空间？实际上花的篇幅并不大，实际上花的篇幅并不大，同学们能理解吗？
就是说关于科幻的解释啊，这个这个花的篇幅并没那么。
我们观众啊本来也不是来上课的对吧？咱们有很多同学这个这个这个。
在写科幻片的时候啊，这个这个知识点过于密啊，密就导致观众跟不上，看不懂，实际是没有必要的。你就像诺兰另外一个所谓的科幻片，我们说盗梦空间对吧？盗梦空间也是在故事上不断的制造悬疑。他在这个盗梦的这个原理里面，实际是蛮简单的。对不对？实际是蛮简单。
然后第三个我们值得学习的一个点啊，就是科幻这个东西啊，也是完全可以和很落地的一些观点所结合的。比如说在这个故事里面，我们说。
这个小女孩实际她翻译成鬼魂，其实这个小女孩啊翻译成ghost。
小女孩觉得他们家闹鬼，同学们。
一个小女孩自己住一个房间，觉得自己房间闹鬼，这个事情其实是很接地气的。
也就是说这是我们小时候都会遇到的事情。那化解这个小孩害怕鬼这件事情呢，就跟他说，对吧？不是鬼，是你在天上的爸爸妈妈来陪你了。你他妈妈去世了吗，所以说如果把这个科幻点啊，把这个科幻点跟这种事情去去搞一搞。如果能把科幻大科幻跟这种小民俗再整一个结合，哎。
他又舒服了，我们的观众就又容易接受的那么一丢丢啊，理解来关于这个片子，我们拓展思考几个东西。第一，第一个思考的问题，末日题材。很多同学在交作业的时候啊，或者在日常练习的时候啊，我们发现一个问题，很多同学喜欢写末日题材。
我们来探讨一下啊，世界末日到底是不是我们文化里面的一个共同的一个期待诗欲，以及是什么引起。关于世界末日啊，末日末日到来，末日降临这个题材呃，当然啦，可以有可以可以确定的说。
西方人考虑这个事情比我们考虑的多，是因为在他们教义里面，他们总有个审判的观念，也就是人是有罪的，神是要审判我们的对吧？这是他们的人与神的关系，我们人与神的关系呃不是这样的啊，我们人与神的关系比他们要融洽一些。因为我们有供奉体系。
对吧你看他们没有共同体系出来，开放性的啊，你们自己去思考一下子。第二个问题，同样这个故事这个情感线我们可不可以打掉？
也不是说拿掉啊，就是父女情我们点到为止，就是思念家庭即可。不要把父女作为特殊的羁绊。这个情感我们可不可以削肉，我们去考虑一下子啊，情感我们可不可以削弱。
你们自己去考虑啊，看看有没有办法。第三，这个比较特立独行的儿子。如果我们把它东方化，我们可不可以应该怎么改？我们说这个特例这个儿子非常的美国化啊，非常的美式这个儿子啊非常的美式。
如果让你把它翻译成一个中国故事，这个儿子的人设，你要做哪些调整？再思考一个问题啊结局。
那四拍要不要结局男主获救回来。那四拍如果你写你要不要或者是你想不想改改？
结局从44到47拍，你要不要安放情绪的那4拍，你要不要或者是你想怎么改，自己琢磨琢磨，自己琢磨琢磨，我不是给你们没有对错吗？让你们自己做选择嘛？好不好？
来，关于这部电影啊，咱们要探讨的事情基本上就这么多了。
这位同学说，AB故事A故事拯救世界保护女儿，双向奔父啊，那B故事肯定不能是双向奔父呀。这位同学啊，从从这个故事的角度里面，由于他还是一个牺牲自己，保卫保卫这个全人类的这个这个这种故事，所以说这种故事的AB故事一般来说都极其明确，对吧？就小家。
救小家还是救大家嘛啊，你自己团员还是全体团员，对吧？他肯定是这么1个AB故事啊，但是你不用特别在意这个东西，在这个故事里面，由于AB故事它极其明确，极其简单，对吧？所以说在这种英雄类的故事里面，就这种AB故事，实际上是不需要去特别担心这个事情上，不管如何制造人物与环境的反差。
你就格格不入吗？人物环境的反差，你是想问这个吗？人物与环境的反差不就是格格不入吗？对不对？一般来说就是以这个故事为例，他是王牌宇航员，对吧？但是由于na萨结束了，行业被团灭王牌宇航员行业被团灭，对吧？所以呢在种地，但是在种地的时候依然体现了他与环境格格。
为什么呢？他会制作各种容具，由于他以前是个宇航员，对吧？他这个这个肯定是一个技术很高超的人，他弄制作各种农具呃，联合收割机什么的对吧？因以前玩火星飞船的火星探测车的，现在弄个这个收割机不这个这个。
很eay嘛？明白吗？所以说你说的人物与环境问题。
这个这个这个人物与环境的反差是指这个玩意儿吗？
有个同学说，安妮海瑟薇和男友这种感情关系设置之后，对这个故事有主作用没什么太大作用。就是想说他的那个选择，他想去那边，然后呢，我们男主我们的男主不信任他。因为你可以理解我们的男主不信任安妮海瑟薇，而选了去马特达蒙那儿，最后是吃了亏的嘛，所以说我们男主是判断失误了，我们男主认为对方。
感情用事这件事情是错的，就这么点作用。有个同学说，第三部开始，男主和摩尔phy各自在各自的空间，这个这个推进自己的目标，然后解决自己的对抗，如何能产生如何不混乱。在这里是因为为什么从第三部开始，他们俩各自推进自己的目标觉得不混乱呢？是因为在那个终点那里，我们的男主看到了。
呃，morphmorphrphy的视频啊，在这里基本上奠定了morphphy一个下半场女主的身份，她在上半场只是个女儿，只是个牵挂啊，只是个呃情感情感元素。呃，但是在下半场她就是一个女女主的一个一个一个位置了啊。这个在这个故事里面确实是有点极限操作啊，在故事终点这里依靠一段视频。
直接把这个女主啊塑造的。我们说由于他那个对父亲的那个抱怨，以及嗯跟父亲强调，现在自己跟已经跟爸爸的当年离开的时候，年纪一样大了，然后来用这样一个。
用这样一个一个很强的一个出场，直接奠定了他一个主角身份啊呃乱肯定不会乱呀。因为就这两个视角，而且解决的都是同一个问题啊。你解决的都是A计划的问题啊。所以说乱倒是不乱呀。为什么要拍无人机啊，无人机上戏在后面没有没有什么具体的作用，对吧？包括得到的这个无人机的电池没有什么作用。
同学们思考一下为什么要拍无人机。为什么有一场父子父女三人一家人追赶无人机，想要废物利用这个无人机上的电池用于农业生产这么一场戏呢？在有一些。
导演的叙事里，或者有一些这个有一些比较大的叙事里面，他有空间的情况下，有一些创作者会在前面用一个小故事来比喻通篇故事的整个的基调啊，有一个比喻。呃，当然了，这场戏也他也可以交代其他信息，对吧？交代这一家人的技能方方面面的。
但是它的主要作用是通篇的一个比喻。这个无人机呢是一个被遗弃的无人机，因为这个部门已经不存在了，所以它在空中孤独的飞了10年，也不知道自己有什么目标和任务啊，这个无人机。
很显然，看我后面剧情的同学就知道他比喻的是我们的男主啊，比如说是我们或者男主这个小团队，这个英雄的小团队啊。
啊，这是第一。第二呢有几个细节。
是谁让这个无人机降落的？是谁让这个无人机降落下来的，谁把这个流浪的灵魂召回了？
是父亲扶着女儿的手啊，父亲扶着女儿的手，手把手的召回了自己。
这也是后面整个故事命运的一个比喻啊，一个命运的一个比喻。好吧，那咱们今天就差不多了，好不好？